my good morning thanks for joining us
how are you I'm doing okay I'm uh
leaning on you to bring us the layman's
terms of Ezekiel Elliott like what is
this situation and where are we headed
is he going to be suspended for six
games starting next week well as of
right now the ruling that came out on
Thursday essentially is that he got an
unfair head start in the race to the
courthouse that he filed his lawsuit in
Texas before the NFL's internal appeal
process that ended so the appeals court
in Louisiana which has jurisdiction over
Texas said this case is going to be
dismissed which means the NFL is very
happy because now the lawsuit that the
NFL filed in federal court in New York
City after the internal appeal of the
six-game suspension was finalized that
will be the primary lawsuit that
controls this case and the NFL believes
that in the New York courts because of
the Tom Brady outcome last year the NFL
will win but look it's not a given that
this suspension begins immediately the
NFL has said that the Elliott has appeal
rights in the Texas lawsuit still he's
got 14 days to decide whether to file
what's called a petition for rehearing
and I asked NATO spokesman Joe Lockhart
about this within the last hour how do
you reconcile an immediate suspension
with Elliott having a 14-day window to
decide what to do next in that Texas
lawsuit he says it's apples and oranges
I don't think it is and I think what
we're going to see today is an effort to
give Elliott that full two weeks which
would mean he'll definitely play next
week against the 49ers but then we could
see that six-game suspension kick in at
some point down the road at some point
before the season ends we're getting
close to a point Dan where it could
bleed into the postseason if the Cowboys
make it there do you think there's a
power play going on at all between the
Commissioner Jarry Jones you know the
fact that Jerry doesn't you know he's he
could be standing in the way of Roger
and his new contract is there any
mediation that can take place here is
what I guess I'm trying to get at that
that is the pawn yeah there's always a
power play and it's various different
levels it's the Commissioner in Jerry
Jones it's the NFL and the NFL Players
Association this is about the broader
relationship
and who has the power because when you
have collective bargaining between
management and labor whoever has the
power in order to give up that power you
get other power in return for it so if
the NFLPA wants to have a more fair
process for disciplining players that's
fine NFLPA but what are you going to
give us
that's the NFL's position so there's
different levels of power and I don't
know that Eliot's the pawn in all of
this I mean he's in this predicament for
a reason he did do something that has
gotten himself into this scrutiny and
into this trouble but you know the fact
that it lingers the fact that there are
these various lawsuits that are pending
as a check against the NFL's power it is
exhausting and it is hard to figure out
where it's all gonna go but this is part
of what you see when the NFL decides to
exercise its power aggressively and
gradiation I think that's the one thing
we can be sure about settlement
mediation negotiation compromise I'd be
shocked if anyone gives at all on any of
this I think the courts are amending
decide if it's just a question of when
Mike Florio pro football talk.com
joining us our poll question yesterday
you could have Cam Newton or course in
wins the next five years
Carson Wentz ran away with this how
would you vote yeah I go with Carson
West he's younger and he's got less wear
and tear but the thing is he's gonna
have as much if not more wear and tear
he needs to change his style look at the
Shaun Watson - Shaun Watson has an
uncanny ability to avoid contact he
weaves through traffic he knows when to
take a dive he knows when to hit the
ground
we saw him to do that I think it was
Sunday night against the Chiefs he had a
couple of guys around him and instead of
plowing into them he hit the ground you
don't get hit you don't get hurt what do
we see once - he drops his shoulder
constantly he embraces contact
eventually one of these days he's going
to miss a game or two he's going to miss
a month or two he's going to have
offseason surgery that screws him up
going into the next year that's my
concern with both Newton England's and I
think Newton is the product of seven
years of playing the way the Carson
Wentz is currently playing that Luke
Kuechly situation you know that you did
you see where he pointed to a shoulder
mic as if that will
is what was bothering him and then you
find out that he's in concussion
protocol I thought it was the shoulder
and he come off the field a lot better
than last year remember that just
harrowing seeing him it's heartbreaking
he was crying it look here's the bottom
line
how many concussions are there before
you get to a point where the doctors
won't clear you to play it isn't a clear
bright line issue and I think the more
of these concussions you have the more
careful the doctors are going to be
before they say go ahead and go back and
set yourself up to get yet another
concussion and I think we're blue
Kuechly
assume he wants to keep playing and
there's no reason to think he doesn't at
some point you just have so many of
these but I think it becomes impossible
remember javac best the running back now
who was the first round take of the
lines he had it's been six years ago but
it was a kind of an innocuous fall down
he hit his head and he could never get
cleared after that and I think you run
the risk if you haven't got concussions
in your lifetime but that no doctor is
going to sign his or her name with a
piece of paper saying you're good to go
the Commissioner says there's no policy
change for the anthem what do you expect
to happen this weekend here's what I
think will happen when the now this
weekend who knows but next week when the
owners get together for their previously
scheduled meeting my first thought as of
Tuesday was what the league was going to
say to the players is here is an
alternative platform for addressing any
and all social concerns that you have
and now you will stand for the amp
mandatory edict mandate you do it our
way I think at some point between
Tuesday and Wednesday they realized that
maybe they should try to get the players
on board with this sell them on this
idea that we're giving you this platform
here's everything we're doing to try to
help bring light to your concerns now
will you please consider standing for
the anthem I think they realize it's
better to do that first to get them to
buy in to get them to sign off and then
if they don't they tell you you're going
to stand for the answer I mean I think
before this ultimately goes if the
players don't choose to sanchu the
anthem they're going to be told to stand
for the anthem because I think the
delete' realizes that is the only way
out of this yeah I was told yesterday
that maybe a donation that
that there's gonna be negotiations on
how do we make this equitable functional
for everybody you can still do or say
what you need to do but stand for the
anthem let's don't hurt business but
we'll make donations to whatever you
want to or you know somehow you're gonna
come up with a pool of money for the
players with this issue
McLovin has a question for you before we
say goodbye
okay we've been giving pretty hard time
busy doesn't know a lot of current
Houston Astros
I was curious Mike mr. football how in
tune you are with baseball can you name
five players who are currently alive in
the postseason baseball players really
no I can't
well we were gonna bet we were gonna bet
on it can you name five I watch the
Yankees game the other night so I
probably could come up with a few of
them didi Gregorius right I own a net I
heard the other night
Aaron shut your Aldous Chapman that's
three and that's it okay if you can get
two more you're you're a bigger Yankee
fan than Fritzi as an astro fan and
you're not even a Yankee fan I can't
name one Pittsburgh Pirates and I'm a
pirate I can't name one yeah all right
that's you know what he I think he's
more of a baseball fan than you are
fritzy I think you might be right about
Mike say I actually I've been watch I
actually you know what I postseason
baseball I mean if you've got five hours
to kill I'll see you on Sunday Mike
that's Mike Florio pro football talk.com
pro football talk live NBC Sunday Night
Football the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience